[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 26 minutes pour faire
le tour de l'actualité locale voici les
titres de ce jeudi 19 décembre faire une
pause entre deux achats de noël la
start-up saint quentinois située à
installer deux de ces cabines de
relaxation au sein de l'espace saint
quentin à montigny le bretonneux une
présence après un tour de france réalisé
par l'entreprise
dans cette édition direction un autre
centre commercial grand plaisir depuis
le mois de novembre une boutique le bara
innovation propose de découvrir des
objets connectés top 3 des cadeaux à
mettre au pied du sapin
et puis les vacances de noël débutent
demain soir notre sélection d'idées de
sorties à suivre nous parlerons
également et des animations au domaine
de dampierre en yvelines et d'un marché
de noël aux accents malgaches à
versailles mais avant de développer ses
titres cette information cette nouvelle
collectivité des yvelines reconnue comme
la belle terre de jeux 2024 elles
rejoignent la quinzaine de villes et
communautés d'agglomération
ayant déjà obtenu ce label attribué par
le comité d'organisation des jeux ou
2024 à paris on retrouve trappe
notamment mais aussi les
clayes-sous-bois versailles rambouillet
ou encore montrent la jolie terre de
jeux 2024 doit permettre à chacune de
ces collectivités de contribuer à
l'événement sportif par la célébration
l'héritage et l'engagement est pour
rappel un plusieurs sites des ses sites
saint quentinois accueilleront des
épreuves de ces jo de 2024
c'est une première à maurepas un scanner
dernière génération a été inauguré hier
au centre médical des pyramides cet
équipement permet de diagnostiquer de
faire des diagnostics plus précis et
plus rapides les détails avec aux
réunions ce après cinq mois de travaux
ce scanner dernière génération vient
compléter le plateau technique du centre
médical des pyramides
parmi ces avantages un confort pour le
patient et un diagnostic plus précis
pour les professionnels
avoir des coupes on appelle ça des
coupes extrêmement philips que le
scanner ça va faire des coupes on va
couper le coran en fines tranches
donc là on va arriver sur des coupes de
jusqu'à 0 3 mm donc on a des indications
très précises très fort et un scanner
très rapide donc un poumon par exemple
ça va se faire entre 2 et 3 secondes
utilisé lors deux pathologies
pulmonaires de cancers ou pour des
douleurs abdominales l'équipement va
permettre d'accueillir une trentaine de
patients par jour
cela faisait plusieurs années qu'il n'y
avait pas eu de nouveaux scanners dans
la région il faut que les médecins si
généralistes aient accès à cette
révolution technologique qui leur permet
de gagner du temps de la précision bien
sûr coût de l'installation de ce nouvel
équipement médical 1 millions d'euros
il a uniquement été financée par des
radiologues de la région la ville a été
un soutien logistique
nous les avons accompagnés en essayant
de faire au mieux pour que
l'installation se fasse au plus vite
notamment sur les installations
électriques
c'est un plus sur le territoire est
d'ailleurs le plan local d'urbanisme de
maurepas le nouveau plan local
d'urbanisme qui a été voté par
l'ensemble des élus du conseil municipal
en septembre dernier ferme est
aujourd'hui au centre médical même de se
développer
l'équipe du centre médical espère
bientôt installer une irm pour ainsi
compléter le plateau technique du centre
médical morte indien
[Musique]
se relaxer en seulement 10 minutes c'est
le pari d'une start-up ski sitio qui est
incubé au ski cube à guyancourt de
cabine sont installés jusqu'à samedi
dans les rues piétonnes de l'espace
saint quentin le centre commercial 6 kg
au propose gratuitement une pause aux
passants en plein rush des achats de
noël aux reportages de manon varaldo
après un tour de france d'une durée de
deux mois et demi 6 kg au fait étape
avec ses deux cabines dans les rues
piétonnes de la zone commerciale de
l'espace saint quentin 6 kg au signifie
foetus en finnois le fondateur est parti
de cette idée pour lancer sa start up
est ce que je peux ramener les gens dans
cette veine études quand on était bébé
est donc toute l'idée en fait du concept
c'est de vous ramener en fait dans la
plénitude donc on va vous déjà vous
remettre dans la position foetale passe
quand vous dormez la nuit
la plupart du temps vous dormez en fait
en position foetale et puis après il ya
tout un tas de choses à bord d'un siège
chauffer cette jeune femme vient de
vivre une balade en forêt s'est appuyé
sur mal de points de tension est ce une
machine assez intelligente qui fait un
calcul est assez spectaculaire du cordes
certains sièges massants qui nous ramène
un petit peu un état d'hypnose mélange
d'hypnose et de méditation
cette femme est sophrologue et à tester
la cabine sic you la séance dure une
dizaine de minutes
on nous casse les pieds éléments en plus
parce qu'un massage du dos des épaules
en feront pas avoir ce genre de choses
avec effectivement delà de la musique
douce et puis une voix qui peut nous
emporter
dans d'autres espaces pour permettre un
guinéen lâcher prise c'est avec un tour
de france que si kyo s'est fait
connaître dans plus de quinze villes
cette start up propose un financement
participatif
les gens vont être intéressés au chiffre
d'affaires pendant cinq ans ils vont
pouvoir récupérer jusqu'à trois fois la
mise et l'idée en fait c'est qu'on a mis
un ticket d'entrée qui est le plus bas
possible c'est à partir de 50 euros si
kyo a collecté 25 1850 euros avec ce
tour de france
il fait étape à l'espace 50 ans jusqu'au
samedi 21 décembre à quelques jours de
noël justement direction deux autres
centres commerciaux westfield parly 2 et
vélizy 2 une période préparé depuis
plusieurs mois années d'autant plus
importante depuis le rachat du groupe
ouest fil par unibail rodamco avec des
changements stratégiques à la clé les
précisions avec ce sujet de nicolas
landry et michael et demi d'euros depuis
le rachat en 2018 de west fil par
unibail rodamco pour plus de 20
milliards d'euros
la marque s'affiche sur les murs du
centre commercial vélizy 2 depuis
septembre 2019 avec un changement
stratégique de nouvelles possibilités et
une augmentation de la fréquentation
wasyl c'est vraiment le standard le
label mondialement reconnu par les
grandes marques internationales et nous
serons mieux en mesure de faire venir
des marques très iconique
même situation pour parly 2 avec qwest
field le centre commercial au 184
boutiques et 15 restaurants attire des
nouvelles marques
c'est le cas d'albert combi and fitch
qui implante son deuxième magasin en
france westfield à parly 2
est un lieu de shopping une référence de
shopping de l'ouest parisien
mais également et surtout un lieu de vie
un lieu de rencontre des changes
et pour cela le visiteur est au coeur de
cette cette problématique nous
travaillons sur sur une programmation
événementielle et d'animation assez
assez inédite
tout cela pour que le client en fait est
une une expérience très développée très
riche lorsqu'il vient ici faire son
shopping
le déploiement de la marque l'ouest fils
se poursuivra en 2020 et 2022 dans les
centres appartenant au groupe
unibail-rodamco notamment en europe aux
pays bas et en allemagne au pied du
sapin de noël le père noël justement va
déposer livres jouets vêtements voilà
plein d'accessoires mais aussi depuis
quelques années ce sont les objets
connectés qui ont rejoint cette liste
des cadeaux depuis le mois de novembre
un bar à innovation est installé au
centre commercial grand plaisir il vous
fait découvrir et des technologies
présentes sur le marché français top 3
avec mélanie poker
design il est intra auriculaires et en
même temps circulaire ce qui permet
d'abord la fonctionnalité en même temps
des écouteurs et du casque la seconde
particularité également c'est que il
fait des tests auditifs via une
application à chaque utilisateur pouvoir
définir la qualité de son qui lui
correspondra parce que par rapport à la
forme de notre façon
[Musique]
enfin
aucun fichier d'adressés fourni 64 c'est
quand même conséquent et en fait il est
doté d'une connexion 4g illimité inclus
pendant deux ans qui vous permet de
pouvoir en parlant simplement d'avoir la
tradition orale et écrite de ce que vous
dites ou bien l'appareil bonjour comment
allez vous il est traduit à l'eau art et
à l'écrit il ya le créole il ya le zulu
ii dans le tchèque le vietnamien les
japonais tout ce qu'il faut
[Musique]
ça permet notamment de pouvoir jouer à
n'importe quel endroit les 100 des
géants mettant simplement des écouteurs
ou un casque est également de pouvoir
apprendre à jouer quand on n'a pas les
moyens de se faire une batterie parce
que c'était un moindre coût la
technologie est très sympa utilisé à
prendre mais ce sont des simples capteur
d'inclinaison qui vit kiwanja la
tablette couleur définissez des ongles
disons que quand vous tapez dans cette
direction vous tapez une partie de la
batterie après les idées cadeaux les
idées de sorties à présent dans ce
journal pendant les vacances de noël
c'est bien sûr l'occasion de passer du
temps en famille à la maison ou lors de
sorties et en cette année les villes se
sont passé le mot puisque le rendez vous
les rendez vous sont très cinéphile
mélanie pokémon soir ça pour votre pour
vos idées de sorties vous nous faites ce
voyage et au sein du septième art
justement c'est bien ça grégory les fans
de cinéma vont être ravis et tout
particulièrement les amoureux de star
wars les quais sous bois nous rendent
hommage aux 40 ans de la saga de george
lucas s'est surtout aux passionnés parce
que tous les objets et jouets que vous
pourrez découvrir leur appartiennent
elle est à découvrir jusqu'au 12 janvier
à l'espace philippe noiret l'idée
c'était qu'on fasse une exposition qui
soit à la fois participative donc
c'était un appel à la fois des
collectionneurs privés mais aussi des
gens qui pouvaient apporter leurs objets
qu'il voulait exposer donc c'était là la
première étape
et puis ensuite qu'elle soit interactif
en star wars que l'on retrouve aussi du
côté de versailles les lego investissent
l'espace richaud imaginez grigori des
milliers de petites briques en plastique
pour revivre les plus grandes scènes du
cinéma lors bien sûr vous l'avais dit il
ya star wars du roma les adhérents de
l'association brésil
ils y ont réfléchi pendant un an leur
travail est composé de près de 300 mille
pièces et on peut passer de longues
minutes à chercher maître yoda luke
skywalker ou encore dark vador il n'y a
pas que star wars puisqu'on va pouvoir
reconnaître batman les visiteurs astérix
mission cléopâtre
les premiers visiteurs ne savait plus
trop où donner de la tête j'aime bien
celle d'harry potter est celle de star
wars
génial on a vraiment envie d'avoir ces
légaux et de les construire
il ya plein de créativité c'est très
beau même beaucoup à vous donner envie
de construire des petits ego et sa
demande plein d'idées à des
constructions alors signer en brique est
à découvrir à l'espace richaud de
versailles c'est jusqu'au 25 janvier
je sais pas vous grégory mais moi ça m'a
donné envie de revoir quelques
films-cultes quand même effectivement
merci vela dit dans quelques instants on
vous retrouve aux manettes de votre
émission le 7-8 loisirs avec d'autres
idées de sorties en ces vacances de noël
à dampierre en yvelines le domaine son
parc son château vous font une promesse
en tout cas pendant cette période c'est
un noël magique promenades en calèche
salon de thé activités pour les enfants
sont au menu on en parle avec pascal
terreur bonsoir mon ca directeur général
du domaine de dampierre en yvelines on
le rappelle un parc d'un château datant
du xviie siècle oeuvres de jules
hardouin mansart un lieu aussi de séjour
royaux pendant longtemps le parc a
rouvert depuis le 30 mars au public avec
la volonté en sont propriétaires franky
mulliez
quel est le bilan que quel est le bilan
que vous faites depuis la réouverture de
suzanne et six 6 mois des premières
exploitations puisqu'on a fermé 11
novembre pour ouvrir là pour les fêtes
de noël
c'est un bilan assez positif on a
atteint les 20 mille visiteurs ce qu'on
espérait mais on s'est dit voilà on
reste comment l'atteindre les latins et
c'est plutôt bien parce qu'on on part de
zéro
quelques années de fermeture quelques
années d'oubli dans les mémoires des uns
des autres et maintenant la voilà la
dynamique est lancée et on espère que
2021 on va pouvoir transformer tout ça à
2020 pardon et 2021 est-ce que les
dompierrois les yvelinois sont contents
de pouvoir profiter à nouveau de ce
bijou
parlons de bijoux ainsi pour le bijou
oui c'est bath est un bijou patrimonial
et architectural certainement les
dampierrois et les ivy noir n'a que du
bonheur dans le retour que nous avons
puisque les gens sont enchantés de
redécouvrir ou de découvrir pour les
plus jeunes ce patrimoine
maintenant il sera à nous de valoriser
et de restaurer pour qu'il soit encore
plus beau mais des projets à suivre en
2020 on en parlera tout à l'heure sur la
période de noël du coup c'est une
première pour le domaine de dampierre
première période de noël vécu à
dampierre en yvelines il ya une certaine
forme d'excitation
alors c'est une première et vous me
demandiez la ville des yvelines où r&d
d'empyr web écouter et pour les dents
piroi ils n'en reviennent pas puisque
maintenant il ya des guirlandes alors il
n'ya pas des guirlandes sur le château
mais il ya de l'animation maintenant à
dampierre on a commencé aux vacances de
la toussaint et là on transforme pour
les vacances de noël avec un noël
magique
en effet partout sur le domaine pour
faire découvrir d'un autre oeil le
domaine est l'histoire de ce domaine
dans un instant juste les animations on
voit un domaine des corps et il ya une
serre à sapin aussi on a une artiste
marie france charbonneau qui elle de son
oeil artistique nous a apporté des
décorations nous a apporté des mises en
scènes spécifiques
rien que dans la cour d'honneur où nous
avons des cerceaux sur les temps il ya
un pavillon et pavillons sur l'île qui
est devenu le pavillon aux cadeaux et
dans la serre si tu me sers des années
80 et bien la serre était transformé en
forêt magique et là nous avons puisé
dans les greniers du château pour mettre
en scène et bien la magie de noël
le programme des animations c'est du 21
décembre au 5 janvier c'est assez riche
promenades en calèche qui est d'ailleurs
l'une des spécialités du domaine de
dampierre et où il ya un projet de musée
de calèches qui voilà donc en réflexion
c'est puisque réflexion puisque enfin je
vais pas tout annoncé mais en tout cas
en 2020 les travaux commencent pour que
le musée des attelages je puisse ouvrir
en septembre de l'uva terre voilà la
primeur septembre 2021 amusé des
attelages et puis l'attelage est
important pour dans pire parce que c'est
un moyen de découvrir d'une autre
approche
là les jardins mais aussi de rentrer
dans la partie forestière qui est
interdite au public et l'a donc du coup
par cette balade est bien oubliée où
vous vous découvrirez les daims les
sangliers
et puis le patrimoine qui est aussi
présent dans ce dans cette partie et
puis pour les fêtes de noël évidemment
les mules puisque les calèches sont
tirés par des mules sont parés de
grelots alors des promenades en calèche
promenade également golf est en rosalie
aussi des activités pensée pour les
enfants
alors tout le week-end prochain l'as et
des activités avec une conteuse qui va
raconter des histoires contemporaines de
père noël de magie de noël enfin
vraiment mais vraiment sur l'histoire
contemporaine de ces de cet esprit noël
il ya le père noël évidemment samedi et
dimanche parce que ça reprend pas y
passer avec des solutions de bonbons etc
enfin s'il vient avec sa hotte remplie
en tout cas et puis tout le long de la
deûle et des vacances et on a mis à
disposition des carnets de dessins où
les enfants peuvent dessiner avec des
tables sur des petites tables qu'on a
installé fait avec de la récupération de
troncs de bois on a vraiment fait le
côté bio environnementales et les
biodiversité et a mis à l'honneur sur
cette forêt magique et du coup les gens
pourront enfin les enfants pourront
repartir avec leurs dessins coloriés
avec seulement deux jours de fermeture
les 25 décembre et 1er janvier
bien évidemment alors toutes les
influences sur ces animations sont à
retrouver sur le site internet du
domaine de dampierre alors en 2020 si on
parle des grands projets qui attendent
le domaine
justement il ya les premiers travaux du
château qui ont démarré le château qui
est encore fermée au public alors le
château du même est encore fermée au
public la volonté du propriétaire c'est
d'aller vite de ce patrimoine a besoin
d'être restaurée maintenant il faut le
sauver
et c'est ce qu'il a engagé donc le
chantier commence dès la fermeture pour
des magie de noël le 6 janvier les as
les échafaudages arrive et pendant deux
ans le château va être en restauration
en travaux pour refaire les couvertures
les charpentes les menuiseries et c'est
donc l'objectif de ces de l'ouvrir à
l'objectif est d'ouvrir très rapidement
d'avoir les jardins restaurée de pouvoir
ouvrir pour présenter les collections du
propriétaire un acteur du château d'ici
24 à 36 mois d'avoir ce musée de
l'attelage est évidemment ouvrir un
domaine pour nous c'est difficile
pendant ce temps là eh bien nous allons
jouer sur la vie du chantier puisque à
partir du printemps
oman mars avril va se mettre en place
vont se mettre en place par des visites
sur un échafaudage spécifique mais pour
être au coeur du chantier et suivre les
évolutions approcher les métiers d'art a
pu comprendre mieux l'histoire de
l'architecturé la construction du
château vraiment à deux doigts de
toucher château et bien le public pourra
vivre cette émotion est la cerise sur le
gâteau c'est que ans au sommet de cet
échafaudage la plateforme surplombera le
toit du château qui sera visible et
évidemment tout le jardin et tout le
parc
il est troublant qui cacheront aussi ses
échafaudages on n'a malheureusement pas
le temps
en parler mais peut-être on pourra le
voir au gré d'un reportage merci pascal
teva est devenu en plateau directeur
général du domaine de dampierre en
yvelines et d'autres animations bien sûr
à suivre en cette période de vacances
scolaires samedi trappe organise ses
féerie rendez vous à partir de 14h à
l'hôtel de ville animations extérieures
et intérieures ateliers créatifs et
parade féerique au programme des
patinoires c'est la tradition également
pendant les congés est deux à saint
quentin en yvelines à guyancourt c'est
au pavillon waldeck rousseau comptait 4
euros pour 30 minutes c'est 3 euros pour
30 minutes aux clayes-sous-bois qui
propose une formule écologique de la
patinoire à l'espace philippe noiret
enfin samedi une crèche vivante sera
proposé à l'église saint pierre dulac ce
samedi à 15h jolie et donc vous pouvez
venir déguisés en mage en ange en berger
ou également en moutons et noël qui
avait déjà débuté dans de nombreuses
communes avec les traditionnels marchés
de noël qui se déroulent tout au long du
mois de décembre des idées de cadeaux
locales à y trouver le week-end dernier
la ville d'elancourt organisait le sien
quatrième édition de ce marché noël
trois jours de festivités sur le parvis
de l'hôtel de ville avec une trentaine
de chalets installés de nombreuses
animations dont la traditionnelle
patinoire on en parlait il ya un instant
l'événement attiré encore plus de
personnes cette année
les propos sont au micro de manon
varaldo d'une année sur l'autre on passe
de coûts
4000 environ personnes à près de 6000
donc c'est vrai que c'est une
une hausse qu'une forte quand même de
participants
donc à ce marché de noël d'elancourt ça
montre que nos usines encore toiles sont
quand même très attaché
visiblement à cet événement cette valeur
tout est fait à base de mousse et des
plans à base de plantes c'est la
décoration à base de plantes et aux
après il ya des petits sujets des
petites défendent de table des
compositions florales et toutes nos
plans devient des petit producteur d'île
de france
mon rôle sur le marché de noël c'est de
proposer mes articles de démontrer de de
partager les connaissances et il ya
beaucoup d'échangés avec le avec les
visiteurs donc c'est toujours un plaisir
de les conseiller et de leur apporter le
meilleur c'est un autre marché noël qui
va se tenir samedi à versailles le
premier marché de noël am2 madagascar
est le rendez vous est fixé à partir de
11 heures de 9 heures pendant de 9h au 4
bis rue du vieux versailles deux invités
pour en parler autour de cette table
david et cynthia bonsoir à vous deux
pour donc aux organisateurs de ce marché
aussi les concepteurs d'un label dont on
parlera dans un instant derrière ce
marché c'est l'association romy
rassemblement outre-mer yvelines déjà
présentée nous cette association quel
est son objectif
donc à l'oc donc c'est une association
qui est créée depuis une dizaine
d'années c'est notre première grosse
manifestation donc à versailles donc
c'est roumi rassemblement autres m'est
arrivé c'est une association
culturel culturel époque avec une
vocation de développer ce genre
d'activité ce genre d'animation comme
comme ce marché malgache tout à fait
donc nous nous sommes en train de créer
un pont culturel entre madagascar et les
caraïbes
c'est la réalisation du rêve puisque
finalement madagascar se trouve de
l'autre côté du monde et les caraïbes et
on n'a jamais vous et moi communiquer
avec nos noms compatriotes de madagascar
donc c'est une première occasion de deux
réalisations qu ce premier marché noël
c'est pour ça que vous le dédier à
madagascar c'est faire ce pont
finalement entre les antilles madagascar
c'est ça c'est tout à fait ça c'est pour
tisser des liens entre anti et
madagascar qui est finalement n'est pas
si loin l'un de l'autre
les avis des cultures puisque les malgré
les malgaches la communauté malgache est
très représentée dans les yvelines en
ile-de-france en général ah oui
exactement c'est en est très représentée
alors le programme de ce marché qui se
déroulera de 9h à 18h déjà combien
d'exposants seront présents pour ce
marché de noël
ben il y en aura pas beaucoup puisque
bon aux quatre vis du vieux versailles
c'est un petit espace donc c'est un
marché noël un miniature c'est une
première présentation c'est aussi une
manière de montrer ce qu'on est capable
de faire et après on pense que l'année
prochaine on pourra le faire
avec beaucoup plus de d'exposants avec
de l'artisanat malgache vous êtes venu
avec plusieurs choses en plateau ça sera
ça sera proposé lors de ce marché noël
effectivement ce sont ces produits qui
seront proposées lors de ce marché de
noël des projets qui sont très en vogue
pendant ces périodes de fêtes
là on a des nappes de table des
soufflets des sets de table
là on a des assortiments de pochettes
qui sont très utiles pour comme idée de
cadeau exact exact à quelques jours de
noël oui c'est des idées de cadeaux en
plus pour mettre en valeur aussi des
artisans ce sont les horizons c'est tout
à fait ça c'est pour mettre en valeur
leurs fabrications comment ils
travaillent quels genres de produits ils
peuvent ressortir et qui peuvent être
tout à fait commercial les habitants
donc ça c'est ce qu'on pourra trouver 2
lors de ce marché de 9 heures à 18
heures à 11 heures il ya un autre rendez
vous dans ce marché situé conférence
pour présenter un label culturel qui
s'appelle flambeau car c'est ça oui tout
à fait donc c'est en même temps
l'inauguration donc du label qui a été
conçue aux antilles en guadeloupe
particulièrement parce que je suis
originaire de la guadeloupe et qui prend
naissance à madagascar
donc c'est comme un bébé qui a été conçu
quelque part et qui finalement va point
de l'essence dans un autre pays
et qu'est ce que c'est justement alors
il sera présenté samedi met en avant
première voilà donc c'est le sens de 9
l'an bokassa cqf lan vo donc celles au
mot flambeau
ce comme le flambeau en français le
flambeau et le cas chez nous c'est le
tombeau mais le tombeau
aussi à une le temps boyle est universel
et donc il a une signification aussi en
egypte qui est le cas le cas le cas
c'est l'énergie donc le flambeau casser
le flambeau de la tradition on pourra
donc là l'identité culturelle
l'identité de la tradition est donc
l'objectif
pourquoi le lan c'est justement ce label
blanc c'est sûr dans un souci de
préserver
toutes nos traditions culturelles donc
de porter le flambeau et de défendre nos
identités culturelles
donc on commence par madagascar est
honorable donc on la présente de
l'ambassade c'est ça avec nous de
présence de l'ambassadeur de madagascar
en français un sens aux leurs de l'avoir
sur cet événement c'est l'honneur
puisque là ils viennent donc
nous permettent de lancer donc ce label
qui va se développer donc à madagascar
et qui valent des fon donc les artisans
qui nous font donc ces beaux objets
dernière question qu'est ce que vous
attendez de ce marché quels sont les
objectifs les objectifs de ce marché
pour nous principalement d'où des
malgaches
c'est une visibilité du pays
l'invisibilité de nos artisans qui sont
capables de produire ces magnifiques
produits est également des liens
culturels et de faire valoir notre
culture écho du côté de l'association
les objectifs ces baisses et veut
continuer et de travail et donc sur
l'artisanat est aussi sous d'autres
produits les épéistes et de l'eau
tourisme aussi l'écho de développer
l'écotourisme est aussi de développer le
patrimoine de malaga de madagascar et
sous le label flambeau cas merci à vous
deux ans qu'elle est revenu on en
parlait en plateau le rappelle un marché
de noël malgaches à versailles ce samedi
de 9h à 18h et c'est à cette adresse le
4 bis rue du vieux versailles
[Musique]
avant de refermer ce journal le point
sur vos conditions de circulation demain
à vendredi dans les transports en cette
période de grève contre la réforme des
retraites le trafic de la ligne u sera
assurée partiellement comptait un train
toutes les une à deux heures tout au
long de la journée
côté du côté de la ligne n des trains
circuleront également toute la journée
il y aura un train toutes les trente
minutes à 2h30 selon le moment de la
journée entre rambouillet et
montparnasse et sur l' axe aussi plaisir
grignon pour les lignes de rer
quelques changements à noter notamment
pour le rer c qui circulent de nouveau
dans les gares de versailles chantiers
versailles rive gauche et saint quentin
en yvelines c'est un train sur trois aux
heures de pointe pour le rer à prévoyez
un train sur deux en heure de pointe et
un train sur trois sur l'ex du rer b je
rappelle que l'interconnexion à l' égard
du nord sera toujours interrompu
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de votre fidélité pendant les
vacances pas de panique le 7-8 journal
vous accompagnera à quasiment tous les
jours de ces congés de noël belle soirée
à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]